en
bref
alors à ce que le déploiement du réseau
5 gilles de tours près des aéroports
pour avoir des conséquences dramatiques
sur l'aviation civile c'est ce que
croient les dirigeants d'une dizaine de
compagnies aériennes qui met en garde
les autorités américaines surtout que ce
qu'il qualifie de potentiel crise
catastrophique cette technologie est
installé à proximité des arrêts ou pas
ça devait se faire dès demain là alors
ils ont demandé la suspension immédiate
de ce déploiement deux géants de la
téléphonie mobile ont consenti de ce
déploiement aujourd'hui on tente de
comprendre c'est quoi l'intérêt c'est
quoi le leak études mais ramé brami et
professeur au département de management
et technologie du qu'un bon soir où ses
vrais amis
et jean lapointe pilote à la retraite
bonsoir jean lapointe se présenter tous
les deux de vous recevoir d'abord très
rapidement qu'est ce que c'est ça pose
quoi ton problème c'est vrai mille le
déploiement de la 5g pourquoi des tours
à proximité des aéroports
en fait le problème c'est que avec 5 géo
vient de modifier civile et la fréquence
pour ce 30 centre entre dans la
technique et ça ça pourrait créer de
l'interférence maintenant avec ce qu'on
appelle donc donc un appareil qui mesure
l'altitude de l'avion donc et ça ça pose
un problème dans la mesure où les
pilotes ont besoin de 7,7
altimètre là pour pouvoir
préciser leur interdit sage en situation
surtout quand la nuit ou quand la météo
est mauvaise et donc sa part envoyer des
informations erronées aux pilotes et ça
ça pose que ce sera un problème ça peut
poser un problème sérieux dangereux est
pour vous et jean lapointe est
évidemment de savoir que lesdites des
dirigeants de compagnies aériennes les
plus grandes même là la ligne aérienne
des émirats a dit qu'elle
répond aux états unis demain s'il y
avait le déploiement de 5 jégo alors
est-ce qu'ils exagèrent est-ce que c'est
réel est ce qu'est ce que vous en pensez
bien doute alors si c'est bon qu'on en
parle la langue de le mettre en fonction
ce fameux réseau s'inscrire il faut
savoir d'entrée de jeu madame tussauds
que ça n'affecte repos les phases de vol
calcul des collages ou le vol de
croisière ou un atterrissage par beau
temps c'est vraiment lorsque il y aura
des hôtels des atterrissages qui sont
faits d'un d aéroport où il ya souvent
de la brume le long de la côte est
américaine soit du new york post 11,6 à
tony san francisco par exemple sur la
côte ouest faut savoir qu'à ce moment-là
il pourquoi on craint c'est que si la
fréquence aux états unis du réseau 5g et
se rapproche de la fréquence utilisée
par l'appareil radio altimètre qui sert
aux pilotes lors d'un atterrissage par
pilote automatique alors là on a des
doutes de savoir si l'intégrité du
système lors d'un atterrissage au sida
mandat pourrait jouer contre la sécurité
rien donc le principe de précaution ici
parce que c'est à lui maintenant vous en
avez absolument besoin ça vous indique
toujours à quelle hauteur
l'avion se trouve par rapport au tarmac
par rapport au sol jean lapointe par
rapport au seul c'est pas un altimètre
barométrique qu'on utilise lors du vol
normal c'est un altimètre barométrique
c'est un peu comme un sonar d'un bateau
ils envoient des fréquences vers le sol
série fléchi vers le haut et l'avion
c'est en tout temps à quelle altitude il
l'est par rapport au sol en général ces
2500 et plus beau et c'est effectivement
utilisées pour permettre au pilote
automatique d'acquérir l'avion dans des
conditions de visibilité tout à fait et
commence at-il qu'on se retrouve dans
cette crise là
me suis remis à la veille de voir des
compagnies de téléphonie mobile comme
verizon etienne titre déployer leurs 5
j'ai maintenant et que ça se trouvait la
maison blanche comme des transports
américain le secrétaire brigitte prend
la part des compagnies aériennes comment
ça se fait et ce qui est arrivé
ça fait un moment c'est presque deux ans
que la question est sur la table et on
penser que en vendant donc les créneaux
des fréquences à des compagnies de
télécoms ça ça te faut que ça allait
faire partie donc des contraintes il
faut croire que le lobby des compagnies
télécommunications était très fort et il
faut aussi dire que la secteur de
l'aviation avait un autre champ à
feuilleter ces deux dernières années ce
qui fait qu'on n'a pas vraiment ni mise
à part exactement
et donc les crises majeures du secteur
donc on n'a pas vraiment musée à l'avant
plan mais il faut dire aussi que par
exemple dans le cas des cultivars izon
ils ont acheté 80 milliards de dollars
donc de droit pour le salon alors il est
évident que c'est des questions de gros
sous et là on voit maintenant c'est
vraiment la confrontation de deux
philosophies des compagnies de télécoms
qui sont à la recherche de profits et
donc plus que sous ce qui est normal et
la sas à l'heure d'un autre une autre
culture bien sûr les compagnies
aériennes qui veulent aussi les profits
mais il ya d'abord une culture de
sécurité doc table d'un haut niveau de
l'aviation ne peut jamais négliger la
nouvel élément ou danser que et ça c'est
un élément important est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand on a vu que par
exemple avec les restrictions que le
gouvernement américain a donné que ça ne
satisfait pas nos secteurs par exemple à
la périmètre où le 5 je dois affaiblies
ou à essence c'est très peur aux autres
aéroports et tout ça tous ces éléments
là pour penser que les règlements les
plus strictes mais ça n'a pas été le cas
donc c'est ce que pékin a demandé l'eau
je crois comprendre aussi monsieur
lapointe qu aux états-unis en moins de
réglementation les les tours pour être
plus proches des aréoports que qu'en
france ou en europe parce que je me
trompe c'est lapointe oui la fréquence
utilisée aux états unis semble se
rapprocher plus près de la fréquence de
faire mieux radio altimètre radar le
trimestre en europe pour en corée par
exemple dans d'autres pays et donc cette
puissance là et inquiétante maintenant
plusieurs endroits les gouvernements
comme en france demande que les antennes
soient au moins à 3,2 km d'une piste
d'atterrissage utilisé par les
atterrissage par mauvais temps alors il
faudra voir qu'est-ce que transports
canada décidera ainsi pour nous mais je
pense que la sécurité sur le bras
toujours être vrai est-ce que canada
pour rester
c'est dire qu'en france ou en europe
aujourd'hui quand un pilote arrive pas
cette excuse est couvert par
l'interdiction des jeunes changent et
c'est à peu près 100 secondes de vol
pourquoi 96 secondes au mode ou le
pilote peut attendre dans une zone où le
5 g très faible ou absents alors qu aux
etats unis c'est seulement 20 secondes
en france donc on a demandé même si en
europe d'ailleurs on a demandé à ce que
les antennes pour les fans et les
pauvres sont inclinés vers le sol pour
que ça fasse moins donc dans
l'orientation confins de l'intérieur
donc ce sont des éléments qui vient
rajouter et donc le singe est donc la
prégnance est moins forte ce qui fait
que plus sécuritaire c'est assez
passionnant jean lapointe supposons que
deux mais vous étiez aux commandes d'un
avion puisqu'à cinq géants très
étaient déployés vous auriez pas aimer
beaucoup
prendre ce risque là parce que c'est un
risque peut-être de trop un
nom puisqu'on peut voir ce que des
sociétés aériennes vont empêcher leurs
pilotes d'utiliser un approchant au
minimum si la 5g était de l'avant et je
pense que les propriétaires des grandes
compagnies t de qualifications
américaines on s'est compris que
fusillade leurs passagers étaient des
utilisateurs d'avion alors je pense
qu'au niveau politique les choses vont
se régler qui est ce qui va payer pour
les ajustements à venir c'est là qu'on
verra si tu devrais faire est vraiment
économique ou si la sécurité soient
remises l'avant mais j'ai bon espoir que
dans les mots qu'ils viennent de tous
horizons d'accord très bien c'était
passionnant tous les deux merci beaucoup
de nous avoir parlé de sécurité aérienne
et de la 5g de la conjugaison des deux
merci à bientôt
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit